yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby this
is the most this is the most surprising
thing about skankfest you ready for it
and I think you might have that you
showed up well no no no I definitely was
going to show up I was even though I got
stuck on a plane show people don't know
though before you started let's so with
skank Fest a lot of people were like oh
they're going to cancel or something
like that Brian's flying out of New York
because he had a show Thursday night in
New York New York has torrential
downpour oh I mean Shane Gill couldn't
get out and when you you know you always
sometimes you lie about being late and
you're like hey dude I might not make it
like oh hell no so I figured you were
lying you have to send a video I'm
sending you and Louis Gomez video of the
engine died on the plan engine died on
the plane I got on one I had to buy
three tickets anyway I text Brian go
dude if you don't come this is going to
look so bad onest you have got to get of
you start running I run I run on stage
originally the show was supposed to be
at 8 you get there at 10:00 yeah and
we're supposed to go live at 10: they
switch it to 10: so then and then we hit
the stage at 1020 it was I'm going to
say this about the skankfest fans and
the skankfest thing you walk into the
belly of the Beast and you can tell me
you can you can counter this if you want
the nicest group of people and the and
comedy fans just there to laugh and
support I was there all day dude like
you got there late any negative
interaction at all at 1:00 and I was
just doing spots I mean zero yeah zero
and obviously I was scared to go in
there just cuz people are mean you don't
know I brought Jay we weren't selling
merch so Jay was there just in case
things popped off so I had somebody have
my back I didn't know if I was get
stabbed shanked shot we didn't need any
of that they were great everybody's
great what what what Louis J Gomez built
and those boys at nuts but they're also
good like when we had them on stage I I
was like oh I can just sit back and let
Dave Smith and Lewis and and yeah cuz
remember that's all they do they do live
podcasts every week so good they're they
are monsters it was so much fun it was
great it was great it's different than
any other Comedy Festival cuz most of
them are like really networking and
corporate and like Netflix is there
Comedy Central so everyone's a little
uptight this was all comics and just a
dope hang it was run ran really great
you did well on that uh comedy on the
spot where you were you had to improv oh
yeah yeah that was fun with Jeremiah you
and Jeremiah were great
that was a good time it was just cool
just getting up doing a bunch of spots
and then then you go to the green room
and just the Hang like we used to do
back in the day yep it was a such a good
energy everyone was dope everyone was
great it's such a it was crazy it was
crazy man man they come out man they
come out in droves those boys built
something special I'm so glad I went
glad they did they did build something
special those are great comedy fans at
the end of the day that that's the kind
of fans that you want they're there and
anything goes they're just they're just
they're open to whatever you want to
give them and then we so the podcast we
did with Legion of skanks the live
podcast the it might come out I I would
assume it comes out on the the Legion of
of skanks Network and then but they're
send us the file too so we'll release as
a regular episode on this audio and
video as usual I'm sure they're going to
do their thing but that everyone will be
able to see that it was so much fun were
you punched Lewis
again I don't want any of this I don't
want you you and Louis they're like man
you should see T head always egging you
on yeah Lou figured out he's like y
that's why you get so much hate you
don't brag he bragged for you yeah dude
yeah P things I push things I like to I
like to stir the old hornets nest up
yeah but you don't get stung just I
do oops that must sting put some stuff
on it and Lis was like punch me as hard
as you can and he's wearing this like
Silk shirt and I was like I don't want
to do this dude but I can't give him
just a some you know I have to so I
punch him I hit him hard but because of
shirt was so slippery it Ricochet off
his bicep and hits him right in the tit
and he goes ow ow I was like I'm sorry D
you get silk butd it's you know when you
look at Dave Smith and big J what what I
this is what was so interesting I
realize I've been in La for too long
they're just smoking probably Marlboro
Reds they're like [__] I know I
haven't seen a cigarette in when they're
doing I'm like oh they're naughty yeah
yeah yeah yeah when I was like oh we're
smoking they're naughty yeah I was like
you guys eat gluten you don't eat
blueberries and salmon for breakfast I
probably talk to Dave the most and I
like to talk to him about politics
because I love his podcast um but then
he wants to talk to me about fighting
yeah so it was like I would ask him
about all the like the debates he'd ask
me about fighting it was like this back
back and forth nice symbiotic
relationship yeah then then Annie
Letterman people think me and her hate
each other we and what's funny and you
know I'm sure it was by Design is my
first set it went me than her and I have
to bring her on so you know I'm sure
it's by Design and I think they thought
there was friction there but little do
they know me and Annie spoke months ago
at the comedy store it's all good yeah
she apologized you it just and I you I
don't care so she posted she goes can we
take a picture I'm like yeah and then
she was like all right I'm going to post
it I'll talk to you about the caption so
then right before I'm leaving my last
set she goes I got the caption uh squash
Fest we're squashing the beef I'm like
you're a genius let's do it so she posts
it put my comment on there I go hey I
invite you and your boyfriend I get a
new truck if you want to go for a ride #
trug
walk that's good dude cuz her boyfriend
her boyfriend was awesome uhhuh her
boyfriend me and her boyfriend got a
time share now in Mexico me and that
dude hit it off so well cuz he has
lizards and fish he does and you know me
I'm balds deep in lizards and fish he
has lizards and fish so I'm tell where
have kids no he has lizards and fish so
me and him were like I was like this
where you should get your Roach your
dubia roaches The Crickets we're talking
about the the smell of crickets how much
we feed them [__] oh dude deep inside
baseball lizard talk yeah inside I was I
keep mine outside for the natural sun
and all they're getting big you got
bearded dragons yeah yeah three of them
they're my son's beard dragon died did
or did you give away no no he died he
passed he passed away how does a beard
dragon die that early I've never heard
him dying he was a big boy he he was a
breeder apparently they've been using
him as a breeder as as a stud yeah and
so he was older I didn't know heard of
this I didn't know and then uh so did
you guys bought him originally big yeah
that's amateure dude is it yeah yeah
what's the fun that huh yeah dude and
then he was a big old fat belly they get
so fat he had a fat belly like a like a
pot belly pig but a lizard and ate the
[__] out of worms and crickets and
everything you put in there yeah as they
get older as they get older they need
lettuce oh lettuce their their diet
should be 80% Lett 20% so part of his
death could his his part of his death
could have been the too much protein oh
is that what it is could have been
protein shout to skankfest Lis Gomez
Dave Smith big J we love you guys I'll
always do it how you do nice to meet you
nice to meet you what's going on brother
good to see you man good yeah yeah I
feel like we almost hugged there and we
can hug if you want bring it bring it
hug how we doing I like hugs I like that
energy shoes thank you thank you I like
you got wide toe box on you right there
and that's talking they're like those
Barefoot like zero whatever yeah to help
your feet well in case you got to climb
a wall yeah you or if you got to run
from a ghost that too you never know you
never know I I watched your show last
night bud oh cool right on I'm a big I'm
a big ghost guy that's my stuff I love
i' would love to go on a ghost hunt at
me you want to go let's go yeah I don't
did you start out doing so just so
people if you're not aware he has a show
on introduce Max introduce him just
it's Jack Osborne everyone if you don't
know who that is you're living under a
rock live We Live no we're not
live uh no no we're not live no we're
not live yeah that' be weird we can edit
anything you yeah whatever that's just
good to know you know in case I just
yeah Liv always I see yeah in case I
lose my mind and just start like
blurting out crazy [__] but I I watched
the show on Max not it's not HBO Max
just max I watched it last night with
you and your mom where the you've always
been into like the ghost yeah I mean I
was always like I was a big xfiles kid I
loved that show so I was like I always
enjoyed reading and researching about
paranormal unexplained UFOs you know all
that jogon and right and then in 2011 I
got asked to do this other paranormal
show and it kind of Pumped me into the
world you know what's funny about your
accent is you're so caught between
America and like I don't belong anywhere
Australia sound like from he sounds like
from from Manchester up there is that
where you're I'm originally I was born
in London but I grew up in in like the
London equivalent of Calabasas really
yeah in a little suburb called but your
dad grew up where he grew up in
Birmingham like Midlands yeah Birmingham
he's got that that that sort of um yeah
strong that's great very talented can
tell good yeah thank you so much but
when you start doing these when so
that's appropriation I'm really that so
so you as a kid you got into the aliens
and the Paranormal and then I'm always
interested cuz I'm into it and like I'll
go
like I'll do I'll go to like the mans
and murder stuff like that but once you
start using devices it's a just a
different level yeah like the device is
a I always say it's it's very Fringe
like let's be real like these aren't an
astrophysicist didn't create this device
it's it's very theoretical it's very
like hey let's see if this might work
it's deals with EMF frequencies so let's
see what happens yeah and I and I always
have taken it with a grain of salt like
I I've always gone into the ghost ghost
hunts being like with the mindset of
this is probably just people freaking
themselves out in a scary old house you
I'm going to give you a compliment you
seem like you take everything with a
grain of salt I try yeah but see you
grew met no I know I've watched him I
know you you grew up with a very famous
family yeah and it's very easy to kind
of get sucked in a very strange
Hollywood Vortex oh yeah that's probably
why he's like that his dad's at all well
but but but it's really hard to avoid
when you're a kid you see a lot of it
doesn't work out that well for a lot
let's be honest for a lot of Hollywood
kids and you somehow have just kind of
yes what was the uh what's the magic
sauce for that I don't yeah you know I I
think it came from two
things it was I I got Soo when I was
very young I got Soo when I was 17 um a
yeah okay I went Pro really young I
going to say that's a good thing you
turned Pro when you're still growing
when you're growing you turned pro at 10
uh I was about I was about 15 when I
really ramped it up when it just when it
went yeah when it went past just you
know the odd beer and you know a joint
here in the you're like it's 7: a.m. and
I'm hammered oh yeah cuz your parents
were busy as [__] they were and we were
doing the osbornes and so I I was
getting paid an awful lot of money to
sit home do just be yourself and do
crazy things wait how old were you when
the Osborne's hit 15 uh was I it was 200
thanks MTV yeah yeah I turned 16 while
we were filming the you're famous yeah
that show was massive it was a different
time you know there was L there was less
less Outlets yeah it was like one of the
first that fall like family your dad was
and and then you have this whole cast
it's you your sister your mom it like it
was just like blew up dude it was a
weird time I was into but you were close
as a family yeah that's a that's a big
part of it like I I think sometimes
times absentee everybody scatters but
you were you guys were a real unit I
feel like yeah we and we still are
really close we started doing the
podcast with each other recently and
it's it's great it's it's we've always
been close we've all often shot off and
gone different places for a while but
you know we're pretty tight it so 17 you
get sober so you have a two-year run
yeah it was hard though dude I hit it
hard yeah that's impressive lot of
oxycotton lot of whiskey is that right
did you have fun though uh I had some
really good times I'm not going to lie
those two those two years are and it was
also a great like stretch in La at the
time let's be real like two like 2000 to
200 well I got sober in 2003 but yeah
nobody's oh that's a great story no
internet no real internet social media
was just getting started frienda came
out just then and you can still get away
with [__] oh yeah there was no camera
phones just Myspace [__] no camera
phones you know think about that we live
right now like everything you do you're
being watched everything you one mistake
it goes viral one mistake one mistake
yeah camera phones don't forget they
don't people might but camera phones
don't people don't I knew somebody super
famous who said they moved to New York
because every time she would go out they
would catch her they would try to catch
her when she was scratching her nose so
it looked like she was picking her nose
anything like that anything weird so she
moved to New York she started getting
crazy she would dress yeah New York you
can be way more Anonymous way more cuz
you're on Street you're you don't if she
was that worried about Paparazzi go to
Montana no newor like I'm so sick of
people and cameras man I'm headed to
Manhattan but back then New York New
York wasn't even close to to to La not
even close as far as Paparazzi and stuff
like that I don't know why but it just
wasn't you could be anonymous you still
can be yeah you can just kind of walk
the streets but that's wild anyway grain
of salt shout out to her back to grain
of salt and back to your show yeah so
you take it all with a grain of salt but
his mom's on in the show too yeah she
just did the she did this one episode oh
she just in the one just did the one
yeah um he gets pretty crazy with your
mom it was weird dude that was some we
that's real dude cuz I was I was on Zack
baggin's Ghost Adventures and going in I
like you I was like I don't know man
dude I real f i don't I was terrified
and so when I saw your mom if you watch
it his mom goes through some [__] and my
girl's like you think this is real I'm
like I don't know but I'm into it oh
this is you one this is you one a little
ghost adventure I was
terrified just a shaved
head I was absolutely I've always been
to the ghost this was a while ago you
did it yeah that's probably
2014 before before he got his nose
broken or maybe it was after I don't
know I don't know but either way like I
I came into it like I don't know but get
again I it's maybe it's just cuz you're
around like-minded people I was like it
seemed all real everyone's like was it
fake I'm like dude it's as as real as
you make it I was terrified so when I
saw your mom I'm like I'm telling you
man weird icon she's not that good of an
actor I can't explain it I can't it's
the weirdest thing we talk about in the
episode so just to fill you in we were
doing this
investigation that we did an experiment
with my mom where we put some like noise
cancelling headphones that on a
blindfold we just had a sit in a room by
herself with the camera guy and she lost
Consciousness she her head just goes
back and she's out she she was passed
out for 20 minutes she stopped breathing
at one point yeah did to get medic yeah
he was asking for a medic yeah and you
guys were weird somewhere in California
yeah we were in a a place uh just up not
far from me like an hour and a half away
in uh what was it Santa Santa Paula the
demon was Santa Pedro Santa Pedro no s
Santa Paula it's a near um it's near uh
ohigh it was like a Spanish for ghost it
was like a hotel up there yeah it's a
yeah there you go yeah there was a yeah
just a little hotel Glen Tavern in right
there was on the map you on it chin it
was right there it's the pink Glen how
interesting yeah Glen Tav in it looks
scary what got you to do the show what
was it about this it was
pure curiosity I like I said I grew up
watching xfiles I was excited about just
someone called me was like you want to
go do a ghost show and I did one season
of it and the Paranormal world is really
a tough world to crack yeah like it's
not something lot of people a lot of
opinions yes totally purists yep yeah
and uh so they liked the way I
investigated the fans did and it kind of
ingratiated me into the world and since
then I've just been making a lot of
paranormal shows because you're more
cynical I think because I don't we have
a lot of fun like we there's a lot of
laughing on the shows that I make and I
think it comes across that we're not you
know we're not going to reinvent the
wheel here it's we're looking for ghosts
and the only way and as I say the only
way you're ever going to prove if a
ghost is real or not it's if the
government can make a weapon out of it
or if someone can make a billion dollars
out of it other than that there's no
money in it this is awesome haunted
homecoming the two you just kind of like
yeah that was me I filmed that in
England the irony on your your face is
fantastic keep it keep it light we're
here to do an investigation Jack OS and
that was the on uh HBO Max that was the
first episode and then the other ones
they're all well because of the Warner
Brother Discovery travel you know you
know melting of of things it's all it's
on Travel Channel Discovery plus and HBO
ma Jesus yeah that's not a bad thing no
they just like where else do you guys go
uh we went to this place called um oh
yeah my mom passed out look at her wait
that's crazy yeah it's oh dude she went
out she's either the best actress of all
time or I can tell she stopped breathing
man I had to give her like fullon you
know rescue breasts to get her going
again it it was no joke and we and we
very much tamed it down because the full
20 minutes is really disturbing yeah and
I was like I don't really well your mom
was dead yeah I was like that's like my
mom dying I don't really want to put
that on what did your mom your mom was
like I don't know no memory no memory of
it she woke up in the ambulance and that
was still think it's fake you [__] hey
man I don't
know I don't know I'm scared now I dude
I would pay a ghost hard C cold cash to
take you there and knock you out like
they did his mom ghost don't scare me I
want I want the he doesn't he doesn't
believe in it it's kind of boring want
the most haunted place I want to sleep
alone there like this this can be
arranged really this can absolutely be
arranged between him and yeah I know
some guys who can help you out here
bring it I want the most haunted
make like a scary thing out of it we'll
kidnap you like hog tie you yes hog tie
just too old I'm not that flexible hey
guys my back is starting to hurt help
help you know what man um hold on can we
take a break B you want to take a break
yeah can we take a little break cuz I am
famished you're famished dude I just had
black coffee I you know I wish I had
wait hold on I bet I know dude I need a
gallon of macadamia milk well I'm GNA
say you this I'm on the road a lot and
you know for example I I'll be in
Greensboro North Carolina this weekend
true at the comedy zone and I want my
coffee now here's the thing I don't like
just putting any old milk in there no
I'm not a big Dairy guy anymore we're
not babies but I do like Omega 7 fatty
acids in my coffee I like a buttery
milky flavor added sugars oils
stabilizers yeah and I want and I but I
don't want it to be Dairy and I want it
to be made out of one ingredient you
want a gallon of it I'd love 10 gallons
but no I mean one I'll give you one but
a gallon are you talking about Macadamia
milk yes dude cuz a gallon of macadamia
milk would probably cost and I'm cuz
you'd have to milk a lot of macadamia
and they're hard to milk so six million
bucks probably about $6 million it's as
silky as Angel feathers and it is
macadamia milk and it's a feathers are
very silk they're so silky dude go to
house academia.com
TFK just add the milk to your cart with
any products you use with the code TFK
and you get a gallon of macadamia milk
free gallon okay you can add their
chocolate covered macadamia nuts you can
add the so it's environmentally friendly
by the way because it comes as Macadamia
milk paste with the water at home so no
water
transportation transport a work yeah cuz
if there's an accident the water goes
splicing all over people like my with
the water you know I got slimed it's
House of mamas.com TFK ah my mouth is
watering so you guys kicked off with
that one which is insane Came Out
Swinging and then we we do an episode
with Jason Muse and Jamie Kennedy
um Jenny McCarthy and then my sister
jumped in for two that's cool who was
the like I feel like it's your mom who's
the engine who who kind of like
masterminds a lot of this when you were
younger let's do a thing about our our
family sure she it yes and no it it kind
of started
because before we did the osbornes um
you know MTV
was my dad wasn't super mainstream so
they never would play his music they
would never like play an aie
you know anything and they would come to
ozfest every now and then and do a you
know MTV News piece but
um my sister and I one day we were at
home and MTV were doing episode of cribs
and my dad was like [__] MTV then not
coming into my house they never show my
videos why am I going to do an episode
of cribs and he locked himself into his
office so MTV's at the door and filming
cribs at the height of cribs and my mom
goes to me and my sister I'm in my room
like doing homework she's like hey you
need to come downstairs and you need to
give cribs the tour of the house so we
were like okay cool I'm going to be on
MTV I was I was like 13 or 14 so we did
this episode it my dad eventually comes
out of the room he's being a kogin and
everyone thought it was funny it was the
most requested MTV Cribs episode at the
time they used to have people write in
to play it again oh my God so we uh is
that it that might be it uh classic the
the down and down one more there that
was that was it I think yeah that is
super
young MTV turns around and because it
was so requested they went hey let's
meet with you let's meet with the family
because we think you should yeah that we
should do something together and they
mentioned something about oh maybe Kelly
and Jack does VJ work so we all sat we
met with the execs and after like a long
dinner we landed at let's just do our
own version of the real world and that
was it and did you where did you grow up
though I grew up between London and la
so we by the time we finally settled
here it was the third time I moved it
and mtvs were MTV Cribs was shot where
that episode was shot at a house in in
that we used to live in on the Mean
Streets of Beverly Hills and then yeah
super hoodie and then the it's rough
around there now reputationally you've
got to keep up with yeah you do you know
I got got to C forget where I'm what's
with that car from 2019 you loser you
and the and the reality show was filmed
same area it yeah
yeah yeah had it had been wild your dad
being freaking aussy man you kind was he
around a lot yes and no like he was he
he was touring constantly so uh I would
go and spend Summers on the road and
anytime he was somewhere recording an
album go there cuz back in like the 90s
you could do you know Visa runs and if
you spent three months here three months
there three you didn't have to pay taxes
anywhere so he did that a little bit he
always felt like the rock star that was
super accessible though in a weird way
like always like um I saw him I went to
I was at the doctor's and he was looking
for an allergist or something like that
I don't know he had glasses on but the
way he was asking for directions yeah do
you know I'm looking for um you know
where room 113 is you can't find over
there and the the woman goes it's over
there and he was just so down he [__]
not aware that he aie Osborne he was
going okay thanks a lot yeah walked over
there as he's talking but there's
something about him that's just he's not
trying to put on airs trying the
allergist give a [__] about what you
thought about him he's like I super
lovable that's what it is he's also a
pain in the ass sometimes you don't
become a star like that call him rock
star for [__] you'll be a little bit of
a well he's been he's been relevant
successful for about maybe 50 years let
me tell you that's that engine is Not an
Accident that's a dude who figures [__]
out no matter where you
like okay I'm not going to be relevant
musically right now from MTV watch this
I'm going to lock myself in the room and
then come out at the right time he just
knows what the [__] also be think how
Wild he was too and just still I mean
that wild Bo you know the story about
him with the record Executives where he
didn't he bite the head off of a [__]
a dove right there in the meeting he
went yeah my so my dad was a he was a
favor essentially with getting signed
and before it was Sony Music it was CBS
records so my grandfather was a a big
record kind of Tycoon mobster dude my
mom's father oh no [__] and so he called
in a favor to get my dad signed it was
like a nothing thing and to try and
impress the record label cuz he had such
a shitty reputation my mom goes hey
we've got a meeting with CBS records
come in and like release some white
doves and you know as like a I don't I
it it's it was the 80s it was a lot of
theatric they're just trying to get he
had a he had a bad reputation already oh
yeah oh yeah yeah watching me it's
like shut no it was in his pocket so he
releases he's that's literally what
happened he he released this duve and he
he was wasted and he sits down on this
executive's lap wasted the the the dove
lands on her on the table or something
in front of him and he picks it up and
just bites its head off and they like
can you imagine today what they you [__]
it how dare you it's like
[__] there was a mini version of it they
escorted him from the building he was
was not allowed back in for like years
but then his album did really well and
so they were like okay you can come back
now Classic Hollywood well I was going
to say you know they he was talented I
mean his voice I you got to you got he
might have been a pain in the ass but he
had something oh yeah know he's yeah
he's he's definitely but it has to be
cool cuz I'm sure when you do press or
you're doing interviews everyone ask
about your dad it has to be cool you
have like your own Lan your own [__]
going on sure yeah you know yeah I when
I was younger I used to always be like
what about people asking about my and
I'm like no I think it's cool like my
dad's awesome he's had an amazing career
and story like I you stri you are
strikingly sensible you have I swear to
God you have the energy of a goddamn
therapist or I've had a [__] ton of
therapy I don't know if that's true you
have you I feel you don't need have you
I feel like dad's Aussie osbor I feel
like he's a doct so at 17 like you know
a doctor sits down and goes like this
what the therapy you been on MTV since
you were 13 yes I feel like you're you
you have the energy of a doctor who goes
so tell me what's going on you got any
questions yeah so tell me what's going
on got any questions sounds like you
need some therapy I need some therapy if
I do I'm going to call Jack how does it
make you feel I like your energy thank
you you're very calm we can hold hands
thank you you almost hugged me so that
was immediately I liked your your uh
your energy well you're friends with
Andy stump so you friends withy you got
you know you kind of if you're friends
with stump you know mean a great guy you
know Andy uh we met uh I wish you'd say
Navy SEAL I was in Seal I was I was in
the team no I wish you was like me and
Andy's a big ghost guy we met on grind
actually we met hun grinder yes no I met
stump at um we did this uh the S Hunter
games like a year ago and then I went to
the origin emerging Camp over the summer
we were like in the next bunk house and
yeah he's a good dude Andy I was trying
to set up a thing where me and um comic
or me and somebody where you wouldn't
work you're too big and strong but I
think you and I should
get fight him and another Navy Seal in a
airsoft war game I think that would be
amazing I I do too and and it should be
every time we get hit we have to take
off an article of clothing this is my
buddy Kevin Mack's idea I think it's
great and it'd be so funny but he when I
told him that he was like he sounds like
a plan for you to get naked dude exactly
that's the idea I would get I would get
a text from him every like every week
going when when do I get to [__] kill
you and a friend yeah they would light
you guys up my God taking on him and
like Mike Glover to D it would be three
that's who my team was it' be a three
episode series after three like yeah
this was your what when I did the hunter
games it was me Mike glovera and stump
oh GL yeah Jesus dark [__] yeah
I know it was it was interesting like we
would cuz You' have to like walk miles
to different shooting stages and they
would be talking about oh yeah this one
time I killed a car full of guys with a
Javelin rocket and we're just like
hiking up a hill and I'm like oh yeah
and there's video of that
I said yeah they both have a satchel at
home with just a bunch of souls you know
like I remember when when Mike clever
tells a story of U he was actually on he
did it on a podcast too but when there
the the psychologist S talks to him he
goes how many dead bodies have you seen
and Glover goes what do you mean and he
he
said hundreds yeah the guy and the guy
writes down he goes well that's doubtful
and he goes what do you mean it's
doubtful he goes He said
I said you realize what he does he
didn't they don't know so they don't you
don't know that you're in the unit like
if you're Delta or if you're these
special dudes they don't that doesn't go
on your thing they just think you are
like in the Green Berets whatever you
might be but they don't it's very rare
that those kind of guys but that that's
the kind of [__] he did where he was up
close and personal to a lot of stuff
talks about it hundreds doubtful and
then they found out then he went and
found out cuz there was I guess they
blocked out stuff and they went okay
we're dealing with something very
different like so we're going to move
you into this room you see Jack Osborne
he's a he's a bit of a therapist like
I'm underqualified for this job he's
like I just got out of uh med school so
uh yeah he's like so this is not you got
a [__] to therapy me uh yeah decent
amount yeah do you did you watch that
documentary stuts um I watched a bit of
it yeah yeah I thought that I I thought
that was really cool I haven't done much
therapy and I need it but I that's the
guy I wish I had gone to from from from
day one if you need a good therapist I
have a great VI I could recommend to you
yeah you probably yeah you probably have
your black belt in therapy at this point
no I'm I don't go that I do I do I treat
it as like a tuneup yeah like I'm not
like in that main yeah just like hey I
want to just just vomit a bunch of
complaints onto your lap real quick can
you help me just dissect them then send
me on my way yeah I can always tell
people that get do a lot of therapy cuz
they'll use similar words oh yeah yeah I
feel statements yeah and you're like oh
wow you're really wow you're really
grown and you're like oh no you just
regurg you wereing therapist for a while
weren't you yeah do you still uh
maintenance by maintenance I mean once
every seven years yeah like going to the
dentist oh hate I no no no no the
dentist looked at his teeth and dentist
was like well this is a disaster right
we have a disaster on our hands he's
like he's like good I'll never be back
and we'll see you later yeah they still
he still checked in does he he'll text
me like hey man he's still coming in I'm
like dude you're Relentless he's a great
dentist yeah John shavs y Hills uh so
your your podcast is what uh so I I have
the osbornes podcast and then I have one
called ghost and grit that's coming out
in like a like a month less than a month
and and so the Osborne's just you and
the family yeah oh we have guests come
in when my if someone's out we'll have
someone Sub in for them but that's cool
yeah yeah we just kind of talk a bunch
of nonsense did you want to do any
acting did you ever I was in an episode
of That 70 show and Dawson's Creek there
you go big deal big deal deal really
aware of the caliber down am a lot of
waiting around on a set lot of waiting
around yeah a lot of crop Services yeah
look at that guy right there oh wow dude
yeah you've Blossom look at you yeah
little CutiePie with that full head of
hair yeah as I like to say I don't have
a six-pack but I got a sweet hairline
[__] yeah really do dude dude talk about
the glow up man yeah hell yeah you look
way better man not that you look there I
was you know it was teenage years you
know they were rough there was a lot of
alcohol too there was there so that's
like bloat c one up them cuz you on
Seventh Heaven I sure was Dawson Creek
seventh heaven two years don't kid
yourself wow you were were you were you
character or reoccur we were reur played
a I was a reoccurring uh reoccurring guy
and I played uh an alcoholic there I am
there I am cute cute um that was now I'm
bloated but um I I played uh the the the
description I'm not kidding they said
they're looking for an alcoholic who's
also a coward and uh and I I was given
that role they wrote it for you just got
out of
jail bad dad all that and I played uh
very emotional role I had to like say mo
yes and on your pod you guys talk about
cuz I I met you through jiujitsu yeah
your kiddos were going the same jiujitsu
place so do you talk about the kiddos on
the yeah yeah we go yeah kids how many
kids I have four you do yeah you fertile
[__] I know I know you still
married uh I just got remarried actually
like two three two weeks ago 3 weeks ago
really yeah four children How old uh 11
n uh 118 five and one wow you're in the
thick of it the best though it's great
old girls too girls all girls girls
girls that's why that's why I was like
guys girls go to Jiu-Jitsu so like you
can beat guys
up and learn my son's my son's obsessed
with jiu-jitsu hard to get him in
involved in much else you know he was
always and then he found Jiu-Jitsu he's
just he's 12 but he found Jiu-Jitsu and
he's obsessed it's really I'm just
loving it I don't care what it is is
your is your is your boy still going
going is he still going to the same
different school yeah different school
now but he goes to another one cool and
then then your your sister has kiddos
too he she has one yeah she had a boy
about 11 months he's nearly one yeah
he's a cute little guy and how how's
your pops as a grandpa he's good you
know he's kind of like what's going on
he's kind of chill you know he's like
hey what's going on I just kind of pass
him off yeah you know he's you know
gives him a little cud my father's that
way my father with little kids it's like
hey back to the book you know the older
kids but he'll sit in one chair in the
corner and he's just like there he is
that's exactly as he be doing an
impression of my dad yep and then we're
done with that but then when you turn 19
he's all about you if you can talk and
Converse really from 14 the 14 to
grandmas are
opposite like my my mom my my stepmom my
mother-in-law like my mother-in-law play
trucks with them for an hour or my dad
like absolutely not do you know that
they've done so women apparently when
they look at a baby's face or a
toddler's face produce endorphins that
men don't so when they see a face like
that it makes them feel good all day
long they can just spend all my I think
I got a trickle of that I bet you do I
am too with my son but my my do my
mother can just sit there with that baby
I'm like that with every and she she has
to reiterate what he does and it's I'm
like it's not that interesting you know
he picked up the truck and he knew what
it was and he knew that it had a I'm
like Oh my dad will be like hey tiger
wants to uh go back in he wants to go
swimming I I'll go with him I'm like
okay and I just assume you know I didn't
drown so know [__] I look back there
he's just playing like solitary while my
kid in the pool oh yeah oh 100% I go Dad
what the [__] are you doing he's in the
water he's like I know you got I'm like
dude get out get out of take it from
here get out here that's kind of like
how I am as a dad though I'm like
they're fine yeah yeah yeah my uh I'm a
helicopter dad oh you are yeah I so bad
so
bad yeah my uh I guess I'm a little bit
more like you in that sense you you one
or I have I have three children okay
three different baby mamas no no no no
two no two different babies so kiss by
one my my ex-wife 15 12-year-old okay
15-year-old daughter two boys one girl
and uh yeah when your daughter's turn
teenagers they're going to have no time
for you maybe you but not me it's um a
stranger to her it's uh it's it's it's
starting with my 11-year-old cuz I guess
like now they start going into like
puberty way younger oh yeah which is
terrifying and everyone just ignores
you're like wait a second does no one
else think does no one think this is
weird that it's like 11-year-old
starting their periods where when I was
younger it was like 16 I wrote I wrote a
whole I wrot yeah I wrote a
whole I wrote a whole bit on how my
interaction with my 15-year-old daughter
is like the nerd and she's the prom
queen where I'm like hey how you doing
you want you want to you want to have
dinner and oh you're busy okay cool I
got and then I saw Tina Fe do it and she
she she wrote the same bit I saw her
[__] man it was so good and I was like I
wrote the same bit and uh so I can't do
it but anyway but that's how I feel with
her I'm always like the the nerd who's
trying to get just a minute with her I
feel like girls are harder I mean I'm I
have my first daughter coming December
15th oh nice congrats yeah she now she's
going to have three bodyguards with me
her two brothers so should be all on
that end but I'm I'm more I have more
anxiety about a girl being a girl D boys
I'm like I'll figure boys I got the girl
I'm like I have no clue I have no clue
it's uh they like to cuddle which is
great love that I love a good cuddle
yeah I'm I'm a snuggle M I'm in like
it's it's great I've got four of them so
one of them if one of them doesn't want
anything to do with me at least one will
be like oh you don't like her right now
I'll come that's so good are they all
different my daughter never was that way
with me totally different never but
that's okay
uh they're all different totally
different my eldest is like my my buddy
she comes with me everywhere she's like
a full hippie nerd pescatarian really
doesn't loves video games loves Animal
no but she just met a baby cow once and
swore off eating I get it my daughter
same thing my daughter's a vegetarian
okay drives me nuts frankly yeah well
that was my deal she's like I don't I
don't want to eat meat I was like it's
too difficult to make vegetarian meals
just eat fish and we can it's a
compromise oh she was in sensible
[__] yeah no intelligence we're
not you have a resting intelligence yeah
we're not going to turn our household
into Crossroads you know restaurant it's
a beast the full vegan like menus dude
no it's I can't do it no hell no yeah
I'm worried cuz my boys like boys boy
like they they wrestle nonstop
somebody's getting hurt they're
constantly fighting yeah the monsters so
I'm like this little girl's in for I
mean she better have her [__] together
she have cauliflower ears at 3 you know
like it's just a nightmare yeah they
both have your genetics I mean they're
monsters yeah just big and strong yeah
and just like Bam Bam just running traps
in a neck I mean like you know the
triangle neck pal natches yeah literally
looks like he does you're like oh my God
yeah he's seven the this morning before
school we're playing Mortal Kombat yeah
he knows theat at seven is he 140 I
don't know whatever you want he's
benching 140 dud yeah he's benching 140
yeah it's a problem he'll be stronger
than I am by the time he's 11 it's a
problem but you enjoy doing the podcast
with the fam yeah it's great it's tons
of fun it's good to just sit there and
talk [__] and make fun of each other and
it's great now is it like red table talk
where you guys even a out like you know
what I'm saying like with the family
it's tough no we haven't got there yet I
could see it going to that area of like
hey what we'll start just getting there
you know I get the if I start saying
certain things I'll get the look from my
sister she's you going to go there yeah
death don't you dare bring that up and
so I'm like okay all right but you can
edit it yeah you want a magic mine what
is that what does it do it's it's
awesome it's like a it's like a if you
think you see ghost now it's like an
it's like a neut Tropic it's like a it
gives you like energy for five hour it's
all natural the last one it's all
natural is that the last one godam it's
it's really good we don't have more
Georgie I take when you take it like if
you drink do you drink coffee yeah try
with a cup of coffee you need one cup
and that's it awes that's why I'm
addicted to coffee doesn't make you
jittery just makes you like of alert I
was addicted to coffee and adal and now
I don't have any issues well you'll get
I get addicted to it
H that's zesty
zesty it's rather zesty not bad I felt
bad I want to be Dr chalky but it's okay
little chalk chalk chalk that's the
matcha speak it's like a lick in a sweet
lawn mow yeah I dig it adapt sweet
lawnmower you know what I'm saying like
a candy crusted lawnmower there we go
thanks brother wait is that a who's
doing katum right now I am really I
don't do katum what isn't okay what is
the deal with katum isn't it like a
isn't it
yeah now the way they do it I think it's
it's uh chin take it from here it's it's
been around for thousands of years boom
soble heroin and cocain so it doesn't it
kind of like binds to the same receptors
as like if you did opioids right but
it's not an opioid okay so it's just
it's it's been around forever and it's
it's natural it's a dried Leaf it's
crushed and Farmers used to use it to
keep you know if you take a little bit
you have energy if you take a little bit
more you get sedated a little bit so I
mean I've been doing it for I don't know
how long there's different strands I've
been
since I met Chim we've both been doing
it he do a lot more than me but I I cut
my dose down a lot though but anytime
the government's like trying to sanction
things like what's going on here yeah
because people started using natural
this you know natural stuff for pain and
for other stuff and then obviously FDA
is trying to that's when I jump on board
I'm like is this where we find out
you're the katum
K I'm not making I'm the Pablo you just
like chainsaw a guy in half cuz he
forgot to pay
you did you ever see that did you ever
see that video well no the the cartel
they chainsaw like the like a woman's
head off no I've seen those it's the
Gest thing you've ever seen no I can't
watch that stuff yeah I cannot watch
that I I saw it and I saw the Dan new
pearl one too yeah you can I can't watch
it oh no it mess me up for weeks I don't
watch them any longer yeah you can't
unsee things the brutality is so bad
with the cartel like how they just don't
look at humans the same they don't value
it the way we do they just they just ch
it ruin entire week what what I guess it
was she was she coughed yeah she coughed
exactly yeah Jesus Christ she was
involved in like a rival faction or
whatever and they just took her out into
a field and was like good God man [__]
you ever seen the Russian one where they
cut the guy's head off with a Dull Knife
yes and they've just got on his head
he's like like I was like 15 watching
like holy [__] yeah I don't think that's
good for you yeah consumption Junction
was that there oh dude me me and J were
driving a Sacramento on Thursday it's
6:00 a.m. and Jay's like why are we
leaving St I'm like cuz traffic we don't
want to touch any traffic he's like all
right he's all groggy we're driving dead
stop traffic I mean it's the worst
traffic you ever seen I'm like
[__] and I'm like I'm telling
you he's like La I'm like no this is
weird something's going on up there so
we're going I don't see any cops like
what the [__] is going on and finally
they're merging all to one lane we get
close it's this four car accident the
cars are smashed I and Jay goes don't
look it's going to ruin your day and I
was like no I'm not going to look but
you just naturally but I just got to
make sure I just glanc over just lady
dead in car but like staring at me I
went a no what if me and my brother
didn't talk for two hours we were just
like okay but what if she wasn't dead
but then died cuz I could have helped
her well no you were the last person she
saw and you just kept driving my windows
are
tinted boom hey why are you why are you
killing this amazing setup but think
about it like she went like this so she
went brandish
she
all she's all Deuce gang
fast yeah that's uh yeah it was
dark car accidents I I missed my show I
was an hour late to my show in Chicago
because uh there was I've never seen
this kind of traffic and I was calling I
go I don't know what's going on and
there was a dude who was trying to jump
off the bridge into traffic and the cops
the Chicago cops are real you know they
they haven't seen anything or anything
and they're you could see them talking
to him and he's he's raving you know and
they I guess they ended up saving him
and it turns out he was trying to kill
himself because he got caught for being
a child molester they should have let
him yeah cop I made that part up oh oh
if he was the cops like you did
what hold on don't know stay there he's
coming for us boys go ahead boys I want
to add a Twist because I want to see
what you guys would do but that it was a
bad story right and so you tried saving
it said he jumped I remember he was a
homeless guy just raving and they but he
just held up traffic dude we we had one
over here I remember when I was fighting
I was going to Jitsu traffic was so bad
dead stop people out of their car just
sitting there and I'm like what the [__]
is going on she's like look same thing
dude going to jump on the freeway we're
there for 2 hours the old lady in front
of me gets out of her car and goes just
[__] do it already I was like yeah
Savage but also with her on this yeah
yeah oh this lady they were not having
it just do it remember a couple years
ago on uh I think it was the five over
by like Las vas a guy was racing is like
souped up Whatever Gets in a wreck gets
launched out of his vehicle and
splattered and stuck on the freeway side
what F yeah it was the craziest [__]
ever they had to like peel his body off
the freeway sign it's like a cartoon an
accordion yeah yeah that's that's that's
like my father-in-law he's CHP for 30
years so he was he was I've seen more
dead people than you would imagine he
was first day on the job he's like 22
years old first day on the job he goes
this guy was driving and he he wasn't
paying attention he going 90 drove in
the back of a semi- he goes so his arms
are broke but the way he must have his
head hit it just evaporated so he goes I
I'm the first one it's the first call
ever pulls up all he sees is a headless
body there and they're like looking
around for the body yeah dude wait zoom
in on that yeah I don't want to like
show this obviously but well yeah he
flew all the way up there yes dude dude
that's his body up there yeah oh that's
so crazy how Wild is that look at that
car that's so [__] crazy you imagine
if you're watch like by the way you're
stuck up there you okay what if though
what if sorry it's too dark I'm not
going go no I like where you're going ja
I like you're what if like we we went
like medieval status right and he was
racing his I as I recall he was street
racing I could be wrong so if people are
going to listen to this and get offended
sorry but uh
what if we did like Medieval Times where
they would just hang the body at the
gates to be like look what this idiot
did and like this is how like a warning
like great deterrent don't street race
no who does that the cartel don't do
drugs and they hang him off the bridge
yeah they write messages on the body
yeah they did that that's Tim Kennedy
said that when he was in Afghanistan
these guys uh that's [__] that's nuts
by the way I didn't know that did I
can't get over that did he have a spring
in his seat it said he got he was trying
to pass and then somehow something
happened I mean from this I'm just
reading reading this part passing on
shoulder passing on shoulder 20 you know
how high you know how fast you have
launched 20 years old too you're
probably like driving super fast yeah
it's terrible yeah that sucks but what
were you saying about Tim K Medieval
Times bodies so he was coming back from
uh they had to escort this um Convoy in
the worst part of Afghanistan and they
were in firefights all the way down
there and then as he was coming back
they had to have firefights back in fact
they had like some crazy number like 39
trucks and they and got there with only
eight trucks it was crazy and so but
there was this there was this in this
war torn insane place there was a
village this village with he said it was
like
shanga Beautiful People healthy it was
like you know they're out in the fields
you know it was like a agrarian Little
Village like the Shire and before they
got there cuz they were starving and
thirsty
there was a body hanging like right from
a tree and it was a taliban's body and
the message and there was a message that
said this is what happens to all Taliban
that try to come into our village and
those [__] weren't playing
around Tim in the book it's really well
because Tim had been through so much and
that this old man saw him and he said
the old man had like blue eyes in
Afghanistan and Tim looked at him and oh
man something Tim was covered in [__]
just [__] and everything and the the old
man just took him into his arms and Tim
started crying and they said they were
there and they fed him they hung out
with him and they were the most
beautiful people in the world and he
thinks he still feels like they all
thought it was a dream they were like
did we just go into a portal in the
middle of a wart toown and then as they
were driving away that body was just
hanging there just a [__] message you
just hear like a bell toll somewhere out
of nowhere and a dog
oh yep and Jack Osborne's there and uh
just sit down you're the therapist yeah
sit around come
around yeah that's uh man are you going
to let your kids drive do your kids
drive dude it's it's it scares the [__]
out of me yeah it scares the [__] out of
me cuz it's un social media scares me
more than driving really yeah that's
that's interesting for sure yeah
especially like boys whatever the a
young girl on social media especially
this day and age and all those creeps
yeah no I'm not I have a my Sol I
figured out my my my hack for that with
my daughter is I uh I got her an Apple
Watch so she can make calls she can text
oh wow but no social media no social
media can't set the web and I know where
she is at all times oh that's brilliant
that's really good yeah that's my that's
my like parent and hack it's a good one
H my daughter's been really good about
not being on it like they she just
doesn't she refuses to engage like I
asked her about Twitter she stopped me
she goes Twitter's the most toxic place
in the world nobody my age is on it kids
aren't on Twitter but Tik Tok yeah yeah
only fans Not
yeah Tik tokn these kids man just it's a
pipeline Tik Tok is a pipeline for only
fans yeah dude yeah it's tough to stop
we'll figure it out I think that kids
are going to I think people will always
figure out that there're are bad
whenever there's a bad Shadow side to
things you you figure it out I mean
people are not only took 30 years with
cigarettes yeah well it takes a while
but sometimes they'll do it you know
wait cigarettes are bad depends who you
ask smoke
no yeah I don't know if they're going to
figure out by the time espec espe not
way your time your kids are I think they
going through now I think though the
people go it's never been bigger bra I
know but I think the people kind of
figure out ways to insulate themselves I
hope yeah I think it's pendulum I think
the pendulum is going to start swinging
back to where I'm seeing it with my my
guy works with me his son and their
friends they kind of just laugh at all
the craziness that is pumped into kid
head drinking and driving you just don't
see that anymore it used to be
completely acceptable but but people
still don't people like I've been drink
and I can't or I got a drink you would
never see anybody do that the message is
it's like if something's that bad take
and just die so yeah well that's true
that's true yeah yeah the numbers just
don't align with it be like the age of
death of under 18's never been higher
yeah so it's tough yeah but I I read
Jonathan Height's work on that it's it's
still minimal it's like yes it's up but
it's not you know what people think it
is what with the fental deaths or
with under 18 you're talking about
suicide no I'm talking about anything
death in general it's never been more
dangerous to be under 18 as far as death
really it's more dangerous wow I feel
like bring it up Jin I'm looking I think
if you add fent all deaths yes I I would
agree with that death under Mao I love
that that was the first that under M I
was like okay yeah I mean that's so how
do we Google this deaths under 18 versus
like 20 just go to Deaths under 18
2022 take the number then do death of 18
in the 90 accidents there's so many
different leading cause of death under
the that's accidents I guarantee
Firearms continue to be number one
really accidental Firearms more than
drowning and I thought drowning was
number one drug
overdoses uh poisoning obviously from
stuff in the kit it's increased
186% since 2000 wow and 103% since 2019
oh man so what I'm hearing you say is
all this like let's protect our kids is
it working isn't working huh yeah what a
surprise what a surprise
interesting yeah it's scary it's not
good well we're not heading in the right
good direction especially with fentanyl
there's and the borders are open so more
fentanyl's coming through like it's yeah
we're not heading a good direction no no
wait wer you living in Venice until
recently yeah yeah cuz I remember seeing
something online and you were like
talking
about how it you were just miserable
during Co cuz it was Zombie Land over
there dude Beyond like I can't even tell
you it was so nuts that um like so so my
my wife well my girlfriend at the time
gets in her car and uh dude just gets in
the back of her car just gets in the
back of her car like an Uber he's like
what did did you ask him where he's
going and uh yeah she goes what are you
doing he goes I'm just was just getting
in the car maybe you could drive me and
she goes you want me to drive you
somewhere she's kind of a girl from
Philly she goes get the [__] out of my
car right now he goes what's the big
deal I just wanted to ride he goes get
the [__] out of my car and he gets least
he was nice yeah yeah but that was a
that was a they they would come into our
front yard take the bikes it was just it
was just a nightmare they would squat
remember you selling your house they'
squat on your house oh so they were they
were they were a two dudes just smoking
crack right there in front of where I
had it was like a little family park so
I I go I was like [__] this right now
and I have the gardener comeing I go set
up sprinklers now he goes well it's the
city I go I don't give a [__] what it is
bring the pipe from my thing set
sprinklers up here and every time they
would come I would just shoot the
sprinklers at him and kept them the [__]
out of there then a dude set up a giant
tent like structure and I go out and I
go it's not happening on my you're not
doing that on my [__] sidewalk it's
not happening and the whole
neighborhood's like oh like that so I go
I go I'm the Savior here I'm the I'm the
if not me who if not now when classic
reluctant hero understand what I'm
saying bro so this dumb Dum that I am I
go out and I go you got to get out of
here and he goes no man n because uh I
checked you know I go I don't care who
you checked with checked with who I
don't care you checked with he goes you
can't move me this is my stuff so I go I
know but I'm telling you that I'm going
to move you he goes you're not moving me
and I go no I'm telling you that that
this you're this is not going to be here
no matter what you do I'm moving this so
we can either do it this way or we can
do it another way he's in his underwear
not a small guy and he gets starts doing
this he goes let's go [__] you
want to go and he's doing this you want
to go and I'm like and now I'm squared
up and the whole neighborhood is there
and I'm squared off with a guy and I'mma
fight this guy you're about to get your
ass W by homeless dude cuz they're crazy
well thank you because I go hold on I'm
gonna fight this guy in his tidy whes
he's not a small guy and he's out of his
[__] mind they also bite thank you
and I'm going I'm going to get bit
something's going to I'm thinking I'm
going to punch him in the face he's
crazy yeah so I'm like I'm like I
remember I I remember this I I got that
when I started thinking about that I got
nervous but I go I'm not going to back
down and I went like that with my back
foot so I could keep my weight on my
back foot and like punch him so I'm
doing this and I'm going what am I
[__] doing right now my friend Jay
who is like a real peacing guy comes oh
hey you
guys we break it up long story short
Brian killed him I I killed him no this
is I crazy [__] story cuz I'm with my
so I go so he I go and check I find out
his name and uh I go and check to see if
he's there I would say his name and i'
hear him moving around then my friend
said Jay said he left he went like I saw
him walk toward the beach so good old R
puts a hat on puts his mask on my gloves
I take a Prius that I had and I begin to
dismantle you drove over it no no no no
no I took a knife and I cut it was all
tent and stuff and I start cutting and
I'm taking stuff but here's what I found
found a bunch of really good wine and I
found two machetes he had two machetes
in there nice so that would have been
defend himself or kill me cuz I'm trying
to chop the people who emoted to steal
the wine from us and then there were
there were [__] bugs there were black
I don't know if there were bed bugs they
were all over the place they weren't
even roaches there were these weird I'd
never seen it wasir I would think that
at homeless I yeah and I took it all and
it took me an hour and 20 minutes to get
all his stuff put it in a Prius and I
drove it to different trash cans and
threw it away did he come back he like
get the the house he didn't come just
just come back he lost his mind and
started threatening everybody
in hell yeah dude then I made friends
with him and I told him that it was
these Russian dudes who were Mafia guys
wow I did and I said and they're I
thought you were going to say I made
friends with him he's my financial
adviser NOP
I said to him child Godfather he's my
therapist I said to him I go hey bro do
you remember me I was trying to get you
out of there and he was like he looked
at me and he's like he he wasn't sure
and I go I was the guy we were about to
get in the thing but then what I was
trying to do is save you from these dude
I knew they were going to do this to you
so now I made I became his ally by lying
but then he would come back on his bike
he' come back on his bike and threaten
the people I'm coming back here I want
to get all my [__] freak out and then
finally he just I would have gone with
the black helicopter route I'd have been
like hey you know this black helicopters
that keep following you they landed they
took all your stuff that Suburban right
there they're hiding in there until you
come back dude they're going to grab you
dude I told them you you left town well
I tried to do that I was kind of like
going you don't want to mess with these
guys I've been trying to stall time with
them but they're gonna he didn't really
care no know he's like what anyway I
moved anyway the long story short I sold
my house got the [__] out of there
Venice is back though now I was just
down there the other day it's great it's
back it's happening I mean still Venice
but I like the flavor of it you still
you live in the Mean Street of no I'm in
uh I'm in the Mina streets of enino oh
there you go yeah close yeah 818 you
know yeah do you go do you have a place
in uh do you keep a residence in in
England my family has the home out in
the countryside still and so I I barely
go back though I go if there's work or
maybe once every couple years with the
family or to keep that half an accent
going exactly Al when I get that when I
get there they're like oh you're from
America and I'm like sort of yeah don't
belong anywhere this is this is this is
why I've been in therapy for so long
yeah I just fit in I'm just like I'm
like lost and how's your pop's Health
he's doing okay yeah he had a he had a
he's had a rough go the last five years
he took a fall he had all this crazy
spine neck issues bad surgeries and what
was wrong what's the so he in 2003 he
had a motorcycle accident and completely
shattered stuff and they put a bunch of
bolts in he was in a coma for like two
weeks Jesus Christ bad and afterwards he
was fine he he did that classic thing of
well I'm not going to rehab it I'm just
going to go about my business and
somehow managed to come out relatively
unscathed well 20 years later it caught
up with him and he developed all sorts
of issues with his neck he has
Parkinson's and he sometimes has
mobility issues with that and he was
getting back into bed one night and he
missed the bed cuz he couldn't he wasn't
really you know having he wasn't having
a good night and he hit his face on the
ground and it basically shattered his
cervical spine Jesus Christ so he's had
numerous surger he's doing well man he's
doing well well it all considering but
he uh he finally had his last surgery
he's painfree they fixed all the nerve
damage stuff and so now he just has to
do a ton of physio which 74 I think cuz
he ran so hard in the paint yeah and
he's uh and he's uh and I to say he's 74
with City miles he's not like 74 you
know cushy you know high is he still
play music does he is he he's just going
back in the studio yeah he he uh had an
album out last year won a couple Grammys
or he did that song with post Malone
which is massive one of couple gramy
still doing it still doing it you never
were in music never no no because I it's
no matter what if I would have gone in
music well it's only because of smart
see [__] smart it's like being
Michael Jordan Son don't do basketball
yeah don't do basketball yeah go do
something different golf yeah it's
different though I think it's different
for I would say I'm not just saying this
for comedians kids and Fighters kids cuz
you can actually get in the ring and
like go [__] someone up and be like Oh
rat like think about all the Gracies
they're all machines that just murder
people and I think you know for being a
comedian it's something that no matter
what there's no faking that you cannot
fake being a comedian and you can't and
with music and with acting there is a
bit of like you can you know there smoke
a miror is that's very true man standup
is doesn't give a [__] about anything
other than are you funny you cannot fake
it yeah but it's also like the way you
grew up the way I grew up whether it's
fighting or comedy our kids aren't
growing up that way so it's it's tough
for them to you know to follow in any
footsteps would you there's no great
comedians out of calabases there sure's
[__] good Fighters out of calabases I
don't know Kim and Courtney Kardashian
are really funny
guys they are absolutely a scream if you
get to know them yeah my son is my son
is without a doubt um as much a natural
comic as I've ever seen he or at least I
see the mechanism in which he's always
obsessing over information how to make
it funny and talking to himself he's
listening to a different song so my son
definitely has that Misfit energy that's
needed we'll see you know I don't know I
think being comedian is the most
terrifying thing ever I'd be terrified
it's a tough gig yeah it would I just
I'm like oh man so it's like anything
else you know you just it I think in the
beginning it's always terrifying but
then you just learn to navigate it you
learn to you learn to enjoy the pain
yeah I think I think well I don't think
it ever gets easy I'll tell you that I
think you can you can write a special
and then you have to kind of come up
with a whole new set of jokes or theme
without actually um repeating yourself
you know when you when you when you are
like in the business of self-expression
telling stories there's this tendency to
be obsessed with the same questions over
and over again or the same theme and
you've got to figure out a way to
[__] break that that's that's the
challenge I think all of it stuff like
even like like being a musician like
especially this day and age or when your
dad's coming up like just to get notice
is a nightmare for Comics is a nightmare
TV like what you're doing TV you know
the chance of having a successful TV
show is especially this day and age yeah
it's like dude I mean there's so much
content yeah to be a successful comic
there's so much competition yeah it's a
mother how's your show doing speaking of
which I watched it it's doing well see
it's doing well see uh I can never tell
I can because they know they don't ever
give you numbers for streaming that's
the you know thus the strike but um I
who knows yeah you know I and I can
never uh you know they oh it did good
but you're like is that good in 2023 or
is that good like what does that mean
now you don't want to hear you know the
social media e clipse are crushing oh
yeah like right but what's how's that oh
they don't do any social media Clips the
networks don't do that anymore you have
to do that yourself yeah they don't get
it I knew that was the case when my when
we started doing really well with the
podcast and it started changing
everything and MoneyWise everything and
my agent I remember at Innovative had no
idea what I what I was doing with a
podcast like was just like they made fun
of you yeah you doing listen you can do
this TV show and you can make this money
and I'm like hey I'm doing way better
than that on a podcast they just had no
idea they were all behind the ball but
now the first thing I do is pitch people
podcast because there's money into it
yeah so ca's like yeah well Sig do you
want a podcast yeah that's what they do
now wait what's going on with that whole
debacle you guys navigating that already
we figured it out figur it out it was a
nightmare that's the other thing about
podcasting is you know it is the wild
west so this isn't the first time we've
been stolen from so it's tough man it's
yeah definitely who who who who does all
your podcast stuff um so I my produces
it and I have an ad sales guy in house
uh he's sort of he's super Boutique he's
been he did like all of Kevin Smith
stuff he was Kevin great he was one of
like the early ad sales guys in the
podcast world so that's what you want
yeah and I've known him 20 years with us
if you want to know the real story it's
the coffeezilla thing people are writing
some [__] about what they think they
don't know what the [__] they're talking
about we figured out a way to get paid
over a two-year period oh cool and um it
was it was it was H for a touch and go
power drills or train train Souls
involved there was well you know that's
when you want you want some chainsaws
and you want an open field and you want
a group of you want a cartel there are
times in life when you're in business
where you wish you were in a cartel so
you could go and [__] clean house
because some people I guess when as you
get older you start to realize I'm sure
you've re realized this being in the
spotlight there are people that are the
biggest [__] on the planet including
in the Press who just want a story
whatever they want and it's just the way
it is you and and you get around really
well people who been in the spotlight a
long time they just go they're just like
it's like what are you going to try to
fight the weather go punch a hurricane
see it's the same [__] thing well
well also like I was talking to other
Comics who got stolen from and I was
like I don't know what we're going to do
and they're all D didn't you used to
fight in the UFC like go get our money I
was like oh yeah
yeah you're the heavy in the podcast
world now dud just send you I'm the
enforcer
go be mean yeah I like okay I'll be
right back well you could that you could
do that like one
time my wife and I my wife and I
answered the door and he had to drop
something off and it was like a it was
like a Sunday it was like a cozy day and
we were about to sit down we had our
like little slippers on I had my cozy
stuff we were going to watch a movie I
had a bottle of wine oh was it from the
homeless and camer it was not from thank
you for the call back drank the homeless
gu wine before that Brendon was still
fighting and me and my beautiful wife
and we were all was in brenwood I think
no it was in it was in actually it was
in Santa Monica but the expensive part
Sant it was on the left side North yeah
the right right I was spending way too
much on rent so near Montana yes that's
exactly where it was and we're just
there big wide streets clean streets and
and I was just like I think you the door
in a we both did we both in like our
little the door like hi and he's just
standing there like this and he's
looking at us and he and he drops off
something I don't remember it was and he
stands like that I was like
yeah and I go dropped off magic I go
okay and he goes you know what you know
I could kill you both
right I was like what he goes I can take
your heads and go like that I think your
wife our banter your wife was like what
I'm I'm a macho guy so I was like
[__] and he goes what are you going
to do and my wife is like and I was like
hey this is a shitty conversation [__]
off man I got to buy a gun I just felt
compelled to do that yeah just standing
there looking at us like probably had
been training too cozy yeah you were
like I can kill you both look at your
necks do you have thoughts like that
Brandon do you ever like sat in like a
restaurant you just look around you like
it'll pop up every now that's why I was
going to therapy I had so much anger
yeah yeah have a set of skills I could
use so I had to see a therapist about it
yeah it's gone now it takes so much to
get me angry I mean so much so much yeah
you picked me up the other day upside
down that was really weird out here you
cuz I grabbed you and I tried to do and
you picked me up and that was upset yeah
I I wouldn't even talk about figh if it
was for him he always brings it up I
don't yeah I don't care so were you you
found yourself you were like you were an
angry fighter no not at all where'd the
anger come from uh when I started doing
comedy oh people are so mean to me yeah
yeah really mean to me I was like oh I
could just beat him up but that doesn't
work no you know so I have to channel
that to something else I if I were you I
think with my temp
I would squeeze them you have the worst
temper you I was thinking about this on
the way here the worst temper I I'm SC
such a bad temper I'll K I'll [__]
and it goes Zer you you're not going to
do anything I'm afraid I'm going to kill
somebody but you're not the problem is
your your anger is so you've never done
it but your anger so bad your anger is
so bad but that's why that's even even
at the festival you're like [__] [__]
I'm like hey man no I get when I get
angry I'm [__] what get you angry you
have anger issues no I don't have anger
issues the difference is between me is
if if I'm going to if I got something to
go if I'm angry I consider it like like
I'm not going to talk trash um if I
really don't like you then I consider it
something you know it's like I might get
physical with you instead of like talk
about it I'm really might get physical
with you like that's how I think about
it but it's not like you're going up
pushing people and do that stuff so it's
fun to talk about you like in your head
you stoop and you have these fake
arguments in your head and the anger
gets worse it's actually worse than that
Bub it's worse than that oh yeah your
anger but I driv this like Brian has
real anger problems I got [__] anger
problems I'm probably like Jay that way
even Jay's learned to deal with it man
man no I get
angry I don't know about that you have
anger problems 100% yeah yeah you go
zero to 100 well where I'll be like kind
there certain things that that that but
you got to take it into context B
there's there's one thing that triggered
me I agree but then and it wasn't
skankfest it was
has nothing to do with gang
Fest triggered me and I was like I was
every a good old time yep not me you're
like [__] I was like yeah yeah that's
where I want to I really do want to
[__] do some bad [__] that I'm I'm
gonna go to jail for like like the the
what I get scared about is that
sometimes you can get so mad that you're
like this you're like I think it's worth
going to jail for this I know it's
[__] crazy to say that well no you
have kids isn't it funny when you when
you get that rage and you're like oh you
totally rationalized it yeah yeah maybe
I'll just go to jails might be worth it
like what year I mean well it's
California now you might you might get a
slap on the wrist I'm fine yeah you know
but sir you killed everyone I know I
killed everyone but let me
explain listen I I get it I messed up
but here's why yeah but I'm not Zen like
Jack OS no believe me I'm not the amount
of times that like I get called by
everyone in my you've got anger issues
they say it all the time really well
it's because you know what it is with me
I I will speak what I'm thinking
thinking when I'm pissed off instead of
just sitting there being like Ste I make
a lot of mistakes too with that yeah yes
but you should the move is to wait yep p
calm down and then articulate yeah but
see I also blow up fine you right right
like I blow up I lose my mind but then
I'm fine yeah yeah but let me just go
crazy explode and then you come back
down yeah my phone was [__] up
yesterday and I we had guests and I was
I was I was freaking out I was like this
[__] phone this but and it was
so inappropriate that the guest and my
wife was like hey what are you doing I
got [__] phone [__] [__] and I
had let it out yeah that won't get to me
it's other stuff like that technical
stuff there's nothing you do I'm like
what do you find like doing Jiu-Jitsu or
because you do Jiu-Jitsu right yeah but
not not now I need to do that I was
boxing a lot that was good that was that
would I think just anything
working I me you're physically tired you
kind of just like that that was the
biggest thing the therapist told me it's
like God I know this why am I paying
this dumbass hundreds of dollars to tell
me to work out cuz he's like you he's
like you're looking at working out just
for your body it's for it's more for
your your brain for your mind yeah
there's the whole thing an outlet I was
like yeah you're right you're right
here's your money yeah now I'm going to
go work out and never be bad you are
right though I get super angry yeah you
have Angry issues it's all
good I don't I mean it's all good yeah
yeah you need to talk to somebody
whatever you try gardening no I don't
have a garden but I I could do that I I
what could you do to get your mind off
of it I think just training like doing
Jitsu or something but I'm not going to
do that not going do that let you know
why I'm not you want to
know6 why I got to warm up for an hour
before I do that like I can't no at 56
no let's talk about something you could
really do yeah CrossFit yeah I kind of
do you won't get injured with that I
kind of do do that yeah cu no one gets
injured with cross so safe not ever what
else could you do like that uh box again
that's fun again it's not happening
Daddy Let's some real [__] you could do
hot yoga No you get tired no boxing is
good you could suck a bunch buch of
dudes off what I'm just spit me Jack are
spitballing ideas dude spitballing ideas
spitball the dudes off to you and star
only fans that's both world big money
there pictures of your feet sonas what
should I do we have a new get your out
what's your tell me your last name again
tavasol it's a great name I'm never
going to get your last name right
struggle with names is going to
hopefully be joining us and you know
what's funny snaz I said to Brendan what
about that that gal we were talking
about I liked her she was cool and he
said you said something about her so's
the plan she's be the next Special K yes
I see you think I just brought around
feminine intelligent femin provide yeah
you know what should I do what do you
think what do you do to BL we need to
call us therapist yeah I'll leave you as
number he's good dude yeah yeah all
right maybe pilates pilates is good it's
a good toning thing it won't do it for
me it's not no it's not going work for
Brian running no I work out it's fine I
I know what to do I'll just work I work
at it I but you work out to like
exhaustion like at the end of the day
you just like yeah that's what you need
I do that sometimes and I feel good oh I
know what you should do what find one of
those rage rooms have you ever been
where you destroy everything no it's the
greatest [__] ever ra that's not a bad
idea and we'll film it for Content yeah
you go in they give you they have all
these like baseball bats cricket bats
whatever IR medieval SP yeah go what you
go in there you just wreck everything
you destroy everything and you could
like even request like oh I want I hate
laundry machines fill it with laundry
machines oh like oh can you put my dad's
face on the doll yeah damn look at that
I made that up I don't
know that's pretty cool ah don't take
pictures like that though right rag no
that looks like an AB comian Fitch rage
room that's pretty cool though it's a
great outl that's a good idea dude you
get exhausted how much is it Chen maybe
we should start a Gund it's good workout
what do you do I destroy things 6 oh
recruit recruit wa includes 34 breakable
glass items a helmet with Shield gloves
and overalls weapons and tools for
Raging okay Warrior Pack include 64
that's too much work 64 breakable glass
items and a 10-minute car smashing
smashing o is it a new car or an old car
though that' be an old
one I would pay 120 to smash up a Tesla
he's like is it new car that no meaning
like has the car already been like
beaten up a bit or is it it's probably
the res o Birthday Bash 90 bucks
includes uh that's where your next bir
five glass and then you get a nice
souvenir a birthday setup a banner
balloons for me what about painball yeah
that'd be fun or real bullets but that's
not something you could do yeah go go to
like find some like you know Eastern
European yeah yeah like hostile type
thing I'll hunt you is that what you're
looking for no no no uh you could just
no you put your face in like war paint
I'll hunt you like a dare you I know you
dress up like a little dare and I just
hunt you down is this tues do I get a
gun too no no no bare hands what do you
mean's he's going to Bare hand brokeback
you bro yeah like really hold you down
going grab
me no don't but that's to be something
you do consistently I can't hunt you
every Tuesday uh I went to black house I
was going to sign it for classes it's
not for you you got to do something that
you're not going to get hurt and you're
going to be consistent boxing I won't
get hurt if I as long as I don't
Spar I guess you could hit Ms yeah did
you see uh speaking of sparring did you
see zaka bugs he yeah he's like might
need to change my avatar got two black
eyes today yeah like oh let me see oh
man this guy's trying so hard to changes
over like no that's from summoning
Congress dipping the nuts
and he loves having black eyes black
eyes there he got tagged in the nose
yeah look oh there you go yeah it's the
blood went to your eyes look dark eye he
has no soul in those eyes look at that
no dude he's a robot that guy is just
sure he is a lovely guy sure but like
maybe you see the Tweety post with his
wife he's like typical day at the
Zuckerberg's and he's like she she texts
him she's like hey babe why is there an
octagon in our backyard there's supposed
to be flowers there he's like whoops
sorry it's like hey I don't know what PR
team told you that this is like a tough
guy move well it's yeah he's trying to
like lean into like the Bro movement
he's like oh he might just be fascinated
with jiu-jitsu which is something worth
being fascinated by sure you know there
it is did you see the O I put in the
backyard yes I saw it Mark it looks
awesome Mark we have plenty of yard
space I've been working on that grass
for two years pretty funny though they
don't have
iPhones oh
interesting I don't believe it yeah
they're on that that well that's
WhatsApp doesn't he own WhatsApp yeah
isn't that a part of Facebook a chan oh
is it yeah all right Chim what do you
got give some current events all right
first one like said Mark
oh that's you see the channel of Jones
he start crying when he he goes you
think my boy hernandz killed himself
starts crying he did like an IG live
started crying started talking like kind
of crazy stuff he's Jon Jones brother he
was he was a uh he was a pro ball DN for
the Arizona Cardinals signed a
three-year I think 90 million or $120
million deal with the Raiders and has
just gone down a weird road so now he's
been released they think it's CT or
something I I don't know what you uh up
too Play that video I mean clearly the
guy's going through it really clearly
needs Jack as a therapist imagine
imagine if President Obama someh to body
jump imagine if President Obama can some
body jump he looks just like John don't
he he looks he looks like
him
huh oh yeah know what Josh MC did to air
herandez
wait they don't know what happened on
Aon Hernandez and Josh new
Daniels all right y'all talk to me right
now because I I want to podcast about
that if y'all don't know what happened
really Aon
Hernandez y' thought Aon in
jail oh he's not well
M get ready for this y'all thought Chico
killed himself in
jail y'all thought Chico killed himself
in
jail yeah is he on is that mushrooms you
think could be he might be on some kind
of a hallucinogenic yeah that like that
that th process felt very psilocybon
yeah something's going on sounds like
you make a good fire though yeah yeah
he's on a he's on a spirit Quest
yeah I think he's on something that that
looks like he's yeah yeah a Mania yeah
yeah see he's you think it's you think
it could be CT or something we always
everyone jumps to CT I he might just be
crazy you know like there some guys just
they want Chu with CT he might just be
bat [__] crazy like he's always been a
little off yeah I think he's in jail
right now for what though no he was he
relas got kicked off the Raiders yeah
violated a protective order oh is it
protective order like for him I believe
it was for someone else man he was such
a good football player
though I mean I don't know what's going
on with that golden womb of his mothers
but she's got three
Superstars sure but so since serious
issues oh yeah mental health yeah so
since his brother is fighting like one
of the biggest fights of his life like
soon right Jon Jones I wonder how much
this is going to mess him up I don't
know o yeah probably not much bud yeah
so Jon Jones The Greatest BR knows Jon
Jones personally how to compartmentalize
things yeah but I mean this is pretty
bad I think John would be fun fine
they'll get him help too are they are
they super close the the brothers uh
online they seem like they are as far as
like you know did you were you train
with him yeah not never with Chandler
with the older brother oh you did yeah
he's
great wait was it and and you'd say his
two older brothers are better athletes
than John yes yeah for sure was
it show Jon Jones a kick was it Jon
Jones no no that was Anderson Sil
Anderson Sil showed him the front kick
that's what he said yeah John Claude
vanam showed uh the Diaz Bros kicks oh I
would actually take some advice from
jcvd yeah he's my hero as a kid you
should sir yeah he's my hero as a young
man yeah Blood Sport oh my God you know
he's a playable character in Mortal
Kombat he is yeah so Sylvester Sloan
Arnold Schwarz RoboCop uh Mortal Kombat
11 so the one right before this when you
when you actually select JC BT does he
just hit Kum
Kum death
touch o I don't know how much you care
about this but yeah so someone is
charged in the Tupac Shakur murder he
was like a gang leader and he was the
one that was like involved in when Tupac
and I think uh what's homeboy's name
biggie no KN sh Knight sh Knight beat up
this guy in a casino so that guy
apparently wanted retaliation and then
hired the whatever the killing of tup
pops so he just hired The Killing but he
didn't actually do the kill this is what
I yeah this this is what I so didn't the
the guy that got arrested though he said
he was driving the car and it was
someone in the back seat that like shot
I think you might be right on
orchestrated the shooting in the matter
of hours after the rapper and others
attacked Dave's nephew the same day Dave
is the only suspect in the case who was
still alive yeah he's the only one
that's alive really all the other gang
members are dead that's crazy shot wow
Blood In Blood Out dude right there he
looks young you got to wait for so long
if that's if it's true damn Dwayne Keith
Keith D what is a guy like that do now
what's he been doing I wonder he might
be an OG yeah no he he I saw the
interview with him because he he
essentially Rats on himself he explains
the whole story and how he was driving
one way and Tupac was in a car coming
the other and then they flipped around
and he goes but it was trying to get a
book deal like hey no dumbass you're
going to prison it's crazy that they got
away with that in that crowded in
area 96 Camas it was off it was off the
strip
somewhere they were cuz they were out a
I thought it was right off uh like by
MGM I think it was but I think it was
like behind it it was like some yeah it
wasn't wasn't right thatas wasn't a lot
of people around then Biggie got shot
right right off like Fairfax by the
museum there
right I didn't know it was there you go
wow I didn't know it was that Davis
talked himself right into
jail I wonder why he decided to come out
with it well for the views he was trying
to get his uh you know Tik Tok following
up says he began to go publicly boast
about his involvement in the murder and
that led to the law enforcement Las
Vegas Tak another look at his
claims he's talked himself right into
jail didn't didn't Tupac beat the [__]
out of one of the gang members with his
buddies that said Doug we just recapped
it oh yeah I him and Suge Knight did it
to the guy and it was his nephew oh yeah
says the the Davis guy participated in a
2018 Netflix documentary on the secure
homicide sh Knight's a real sweetheart
he's in prison for life he ran over
someone in a raptor yeah yeah he's what
else you got J all right this
is a quick one this is affecting us so
there's a new thing legislation that's
that's approved so far and most likely
would be passed by Gavin Newsome of
course where there's going to be cameras
that take pictures of your license plate
whatever if you if you're speeding when
there's no cops around but here's the
thing it's I I saw it's like it's $200
if you're like
100 so check this out if you go 100 m an
hour and over it's a $500
ticket but if you just go 99 over it's a
$200 ticket you need some pretty sweet
content for
$200 but I mean it's when I saw I could
do some cool stuff for 200 bucks but
it's not going to hold up if you appeal
it because there's no due process like
how do you know if the machine is
calibrated like
cameras red lights none of that stuff
got there's there's all those businesses
popped up where like did you get a red
light ticket send it to us and they
fight it and you pay like 40 bucks yeah
it's the the ticket clinic or something
like that none of it holds up mhm and
there's places like in my in Woodland
Hills there's something there's a camera
that goes off every single time no
matter what so it's like they don't care
though CU nobody fights it most people
it's a great way for the city to get
money because nobody most people go ah f
and they sign it you know the I tell you
where the make bank is that one 11 over
that's 50 bucks dude we're all screwed
11 over that's ridiculous I love yeah
that's rough that's ridiculous and
you're just exactly you're going to pay
the 50 bucks because to fight it it's
going to cost you
know make so much money off those 11
over noxious now we're all going to have
to sit there and so if you guys live
here yeah that's what you have to deal
with thanks California yeah man oh man
did you ever think about leaving during
yeah yeah I have I have a place uh in in
Idaho that's you do I love Idaho yeah I
like a jack my admiration grows I'm
going to get your number we're going
hang out a lot let's do it if you want
to yeah if you want to come up man it's
uh we got Idaho uh I'm north of
cordelane so I love cordan beauti yeah
it's a good
spot all right next one what's this guy
is that uh
Georgie so Jimmy Butler the star player
for the Miami Heat last year during
media day he showed up with a fresh set
of dreadlocks past his shoulders soon
after media day the dreadlocks were gone
he does it just for the promo pictures
everyone speculated the whole year that
it was just for the meme just to mess
with the NBA this year he showed up in
full goth attire including fake
piercings lipstick makeup flattened hair
the outfit I thought that was Andre 5000
or whatever I know
right no one knows how he feels that's
all I'm going to
say like the whole how funny is that he
does it just for media day look at
him there's a place off Ocean Avenue he
looks like a like a lead singer some 41
or some [__] wow wow you know he's a
character Sports guy no not really no
Cricket like a you know from a distance
yeah do you drink tea or coffee coffee
yeah all right no tea ever occasionally
sugar milk uh yeah proper English same
same same yeah his mom is uh yeah
fullblown oh really whereabouts stoud
okay you know that's all I got what else
you get you go you ever go visit you
know you could get your citizenship
right oh I can it wouldn't be that hard
for you to get your citizenship I am a
what you're a Lord I'm a Lord You're
Lord you got the the Scottish title
thing or whatever yeah I bought it for
someone sent to me for like 100 bucks I
do I am a lord is it on your do you have
it on your credit cards hell
yeah um yeah yeah I could get cuz my mom
was born I didn't know that yeah
yeah look into that not the not that the
British passports worth a [__] anymore
it was great when with the EU cuz you
could thanks
Harry yeah okay do you know Harry no no
no no one wants I'm I'm a common folk
that man is uh you know he loves his
Ivory Tower yes yeah
right it here's a quick one last one so
this is the new Toyota Century it's like
a it's a competitor towards the uh the
cullin Rolls-Royce yeah but
unfortunately this is only uh sold in
Japan but it's a bad yeah they're sick
whoa yeah it's
$170,000 wow compared to like a Colin
which is like what 400 500,000 yeah
Wheels
Jesus uh it would be cool if it was Ahad
if it was what
yeah I'm sure they make those they could
100% they're supposed to be sick it's
weird Jay was telling me about these
really yeah but it sucks that they they
don't do it here but I'm guessing if you
have enough money you can import it what
do you drive uh I have a model X um I
have an Aston Martin um I've got which
Aston Martin a db11 love them I have um
truck got a you know 25 Ram 2500 sick
diesel hummings ni FJ 62 oh damn dude
now he's a car guy it it it got bad I
had to scale it back me too yeah it's a
I just revamped it but yeah yeah cars
and guns that's my collections guns too
yeah a lot of guns dude we're the same
guy there we go nice we're the same guy
Jack nice Jack is a closet conservative
yeah there's a you know there's a
there's a angry libertarian running
around in my heart somewhere love love
just leave me alone yeah yeah that's my
alone just leave me alone tell me what
to don't make me yeah agree that's why
you're in Idaho exactly [__] I wish
we were out there man I want to be best
friends we're going to hang out we can
hang dude always Jack it's Brian again
listen I'm outside your house I you you
borrowed the tent from your buddy Jack I
get a few bottle of wines for you
that I have these machetes but it's fine
Well Jack we appreciate you dude go
watch this show yeah I I saw it last
night when's it uh Sundays uh at 1: p.m.
on Travel Channel or you can watch it on
uh Max or uh Discovery plus are you
going to call like famous friends of
yours to make guest appearances yes yeah
so like um Jenny McCarthy did an episode
and then J Kenedy Jamie Kennedy Jason M
love Jamie we were just with him at
skankfest I just ran into I didn't see
him I didn't see him there everybody was
there what was skankfest I saw it all
over the Internet skankfest it's like uh
these guys Legion of skanks put it
together it's like big J or oron um LS
Gomez Dave Smith it's just like a big
Comedy Festival oh cool imagine like la
but comedy oh nice Yeah Tim Dylan was
there so it was funny Tim was there too
everybody was there Tim Dylan was there
yeah Christ stano Norman Jo was there
too everybody was there wow you didn't
hang around well because you got in so
late but I was there from one to what
God knows what time it was so much fun
yeah seeing everybody that's great uh I
will be in Iowa October 13th 14th that's
one show Friday one show Saturday then
Niagara Falls almost sold out one show
Friday one show Saturday November fourth
and 5th bunch of other dates coming up
on there and then the the transformation
on my TRX that went to Overkill in
Sacramento that all that content is
coming out soon so stay tuned fellas uh
I'm not souping up I'm not souping up my
my Tesla 3 I'm not doing that but I will
be at the Comedy Zone Greensboro North
Carolina October 6 and 7 this Friday
Saturday and then D is good nights good
nights November 9 10 and 11 oo in the
meantime we'll see a little bit kids
Jack appreciate you brother hey thank
you thanks for having me Jack Jack that
was awesome go watch your podcast o any
the Paranormal podcast too so Jack
thanks brother yeah